guys before we get started with this one
there really couldn't be a better
sponsor for this episode if you think
we're making good stuff here
on the biographics channel and want to
keep us making these
epic long videos like the one you're
about to watch the best thing you can do
is support our sponsors like
curiositystream so why is
curiositystream such a great sponsor for
this channel well that's because if you
like this channel
i think you'll like it a lot it's a
subscription streaming service that
offers over 2
000 documentaries and non-fiction titles
from some of the world's best filmmakers
including exclusive originals as well
you can get unlimited access for just
2.99
a month for our audience you guys you
get the first
30 days completely for free if you sign
up at curiositystream.com
forward slash biographics and please use
the promo code biographics during the
sign up process
so they asked me to make a specific
recommendation on their platform
and i would say that you should if you
clicked on this video if you're into
this specific kind of stuff
i check out their series called the
butterfly effect
on biographics we're often looking at
critical points throughout history and
how those kind of individual moments
change history and the butterfly effect
series it does exactly that
there's lots of 25 minute episodes
looking at things like
chernobyl the space race the black death
and kind of how those major events
shifted world history
is available on many platforms there's a
web app roku android
xbox one smart tvs ios chromecast amazon
fire
amazon kindle and apple tv is also
available worldwide so again
curiositystream.com forward slash
biographics unlimited access to the
world's top documentaries and
non-fiction
series 30 days for free if you use the
promo code
biographics and let's get into it
[Music]
june the 5th 1968 the ambassador hotel
in los angeles a young democratic
candidate is celebrating a crucial
victory in the california primary
elections he has lived most of his life
in the shadow
of his more famous his more charismatic
brother
but he has been able to leave his mark
on the american people through his work
as attorney general and as a new york
senator now he is on his way to the top
on his way to becoming one of the best
presidents that
america ever had same night same place a
young palestinian
immigrant is attending this celebration
he has survived through war
and displacement in his home country but
has succeeded in starting a new life in
the united states
this night he is not at the ambassador
hotel to celebrate though
some say he is mentally unstable some
say
he has been manipulated whatever the
reasons the facts
are undisputed june the 5th 1968
the ambassador hotel los angeles robert
francis kennedy
age 42 senator for the state of new york
and on his way to becoming the
democratic candidate
in november's presidential elections is
shot dead by palestinian refugee
sirhan b sirhan in today's biographics
we're going to look at bob kennedy's
remarkable life achievements and
how he fatally crossed paths with a
murderer we're also going to look at the
sinister theories that may explain one
of the most
shocking assassinations in american
history
[Music]
robert frances kennedy was born on
november 20th 1925
in brookline massachusetts the third boy
and seventh out of a total
of nine children born to rose and
patriarch
joseph p kennedy smaller and weaker than
his older brothers
joe jr and john bobby was often
considered the runt of the family which
meant that
at least in his early childhood he was
much attached to
his devout mother spending much of his
time going to church with her but
despite having a sweet and pleasant
character he showed early on a
disposition to
fight against the odds and to let his
own voice be heard
i was the seventh of nine children and
when you come from that far
down you have to struggle to survive
robert or bobby as he was known to his
family struggled not only at home but
also at school due to joseph senior's
work-related relocations including an
appointment as ambassador to london
bobby had a hard time
in adjusting to different schools he
eventually attended 12 different primary
and secondary schools in the united
states and england but he pulled through
graduating from milton academy and later
harvard where he proved his mettle as an
accomplished varsity football player
despite him being a
runt and playing with a severely broken
leg in 1944
at the age of 19 bobby interrupted his
studies to serve in the u.s navy being
commissioned to
a relatively quiet theater the caribbean
on anti-u-boat patrolling duties the
ship he served on was named after his
older brother joseph p
kennedy jr who had been killed in action
during the war as a navy fighter pilot
this tragedy had suddenly shifted the
balance of
expectations among the kennedy boys now
jack was suddenly pushed to the fore and
bobby was considered to be a close
second in command
in 1945 with world war ii over bobby was
able to pursue more pleasing interests
and
he was dating patricia skalkel the
daughter of a railroad clerk turned cole
magnate
this was until he met and fell in love
with one of his sister jean's best
friends a younger girl called
ethel she also happened to be patricia's
sister
we have no records but we are going to
guess that christmas 1945 must have been
pretty awkward at the skackle's
household but bobby and ethel they made
a nice couple
had common interests and even worked
together on jack's campaign for congress
in 1946. this was the first of
many occasions in which the future
president would rely on bobby's trusted
advice and support in the meanwhile
bobby returned to his studies and
earned a degree in government from
harvard university in 1948.
he completed his education by also
attaining a law degree from the
university of virginia
three years later but as he recalled on
many occasions he considered his most
formative experiences to be the
conversations at the family dinner table
where
rose and joe senior would encourage
their children to engage in heated
discussions about
history and current affairs in june 1950
after a brief engagement bobby and ethel
got married their first child kathleen
was born in 1951
on the 4th of july and it doesn't really
get more patriotic than that
kathleen would be the first of 11
children
in 1952 bobby made his formal debut on
the political stage by managing his
brother john's campaign to be elected as
a senator for the state of massachusetts
the campaign was
successful and proved that bobby had a
natural talent to
organize and lead but the young kennedy
he possessed another talent which
would come to the fore in the following
year he was in fact
a skillful negotiator and a prosecutor
and in 1953 he served briefly on the
senate subcommittee on investigations
this was chaired by someone you might
have heard of senator joseph mccarthy
mccarsey he was an old family friend he
had even dated two of the kennedy girls
and he had hired bobby to help him on
his crackdown on suspected communist
infiltrators bobby however
did not agree with mccarthy's brutal
prosecution tactics
and he left the subcommittee after only
six months he would later author
a report condemning mccarthy's
investigation of alleged communists in
the army
bobby did not stop working within the
senate's investigating committees though
by the end of the 1950s he had become
chief counsel for the senate rackets
committee in charge of
investigating corruption in trade unions
this position won him national
recognition particularly
because it pitted him directly against
the powerful jimmy hoffa
president of the brotherhood of
teamsters the largest truckers union
hoffa was suspected of colluding with
organized crime to
further the progress and influence of
the brotherhood and he developed a
bitter personal feud with kennedy which
became apparent in some of the televised
committee hearings
hoffa would later say of bobby i used to
love to bug the little bastard
i don't think they should be denied the
right to enter a union and therefore
obtain employment because of
the color of their skin in 1960 bobby
resigned from his chief council position
to better dedicate himself to
running john f kennedy's presidential
campaign it was on this occasion that
bobby became jon's closest confidante
and collaborator
in fact after being elected to the top
job john appointed bobby attorney
general in his cabinet
as attorney general bobby gained a
reputation as the president's loyal and
ruthless enforcer and some of his
actions
are still controversial but overall he
won respect for his
effective administration of the
department of justice today
he is mostly remembered for two
endeavors first
his fight against organized crime
according to author seymour
hirsch joseph kennedy had enlisted the
help of mobster sam giancana
to support jfk's presidential campaign
but neither jack nor bobby had any
interest in maintaining this
relationship when bobby
increased the number of mafia
convictions from 35 to
288 over the three years of jack's term
the mob they were pretty furious
according to professor larry cebato it
took frank sinatra good friends with
both the kennedys and the mafia to
appease giancana the crooner had to
perform eight nights for free at
giancana's club
bobby's second achievement was the
enforcement of the 1954 supreme court
decision
on school desegregation and in general
his support
of the civil rights movement in
september 1962 attorney general kennedy
sent
u.s marshals and troops to oxford
mississippi to enforce a federal court
order
admitting the first african-american
student james meredith to the university
of mississippi he also collaborated with
the president in proposing the most
far-reaching civil rights statute
in american history the civil rights act
of 1964
which passed eight months after jfk's
death bobby's collaboration with his
president brother was not limited
just to justice during the september
1962 cuban missile crisis for example
he developed the strategy of blockading
cuba as
an alternative to military intervention
that could have led to nuclear war
but cuba also marks one of the shadows
in the attorney general's career after
the failure of the bay of pigs invasion
a plan to overthrow fidel castro using
an ill-prepared force of cuban exiles
president kennedy asked his brother to
oversee a clandestine mission operation
mongoose which was dedicated to
removing the cuban leader once and for
all bobby invested
hundreds of millions of dollars in
building secret bases
training spies and planning increasingly
bizarre ways to do away with castro for
good
operation mongoose is known to have made
at least eight failed attempts on the
communist leader's life
one of which involved cia operatives
hiring a mafia hitman
johnny roselli considering bobby's
stance against organized crime this
further involvement with the mob
is controversial to say the least
another controversial decision
involved the civil rights movement
despite the attorney general's
sympathies towards this movement
in 1963 he approved the installation of
wiretaps on martin luther king
and several of his associates in this
case bobby had relented to lobbying from
fbi director j
edgar hoover who believed dr king to be
a communist sympathizer
mainly because he had spoken up against
the vietnam war for more than
three years the bureau would keep king
under surveillance and
even sent him anonymous threatening
letters in the hopes of
stopping his social justice campaigns
but i think that we have to recognize
those of us who
have the advantages that you have and
that i have that we have an obligation
and responsibility to those who do not
on the 22nd of november 1963 john f
kennedy was shot in dallas
and we'd ask you to watch our video on
jfk to learn
more about the facts and theories behind
that killing but let's not lose our
focus
on bobby in this video john's death it
was a devastating blow for him
not only had he lost a brother whom he
loved dearly but
his years as a campaign manager and
attorney general had given him
an identity which he was now struggling
to find
he continued his duties at the
department of justice under lyndon
johnson's presidency until 1964 but the
two
they never got along well and bobby quit
his job instead he ran for the post of
u.s senator for the state of new york
launching an effective campaign which
won him the november election
by 719 000 votes
as new york senator bobby dedicated
himself to three main
causes first he strived to support the
dispossessed and the powerless in
america
mainly the urban populations the racial
minorities and native americans
he sought to remedy the problems of
poverty through legislation to encourage
private industry
to locate in poverty-stricken areas thus
creating jobs for the unemployed
and he also stressed the importance of
work over welfare then he sought to
advance human rights both in the u.s
and abroad he was an outspoken critic of
the apartheid system in south africa
visiting the country in 1966 and
delivering a memorable speech to an
assembly of progressive students
in part it reads each time a man stands
up for an ideal or acts to improve the
loss of others or strikes out against
injustice
he sends forth a tiny ripple of hope
and crossing each other from a million
different centers of energy
and daring those ripples build a current
that can sweep down the mightiest walls
of oppression
and resistance and finally he embarked
on a personal quest
to end the vietnam war bobby had
initially supported president johnson's
military escalation in indochina until
february of 1966. this is when he first
publicly denounced this policy and
asked for the reduction of the war
effort as well as for the initiation of
talks with the vietcong and the north
vietnamese
he strongly opposed president johnson's
authorization of the carpet bombing of
civilian targets in north vietnam
which he denounced in another memorable
speech in the senate
it reads in part are we like the god of
the old testament that we can decide in
washington d.c what cities what towns
what hamlets in vietnam
are going to be destroyed do we have to
accept that
i do not think we have to i think we can
do something
about it my thanks to all of you and now
it's on to chicago and let's win there
on march the 16th 1968 robert kennedy
announced his candidacy for the
democratic
presidential nomination he would be
running on a very progressive platform
against the other main democratic
candidate hubert humphrey
it was in the words of author arthur
schlesinger jr an uproarious campaign
filled with enthusiasm and fun it was
also a campaign moving in its sweep
and passion in his campaign bobby built
on the themes that had marked his
senatorial term
advancement of human rights including
supporting the civil rights movement
helping the dispossessed in urban areas
and the native american reservations
and putting an end to the vietnam war
his candidates were supportive of a
broader
safer more conservative message and yet
bobby managed to win
critical primary elections in nebraska
and indiana and it was just before
speaking at an indianapolis rally that
bobby learns of the murder of martin
luther king
it was the 4th of april 1968 five years
since the former attorney general had
approved of the reverend surveillance by
the fbi
that evening bobby delivered one of his
most famous speeches informing the crowd
of king's death and urging them not to
react with anger he concluded by making
an appeal for racial unity in those
difficult times
following king's death riots broke out
in more than 100 cities across the
united states but
indianapolis remained peaceful after
securing nebraska and indiana bobby was
looking forward to winning the
california primaries in early june
the democratic candidacy was within his
grasp and so
we're back at the start of our video
it's the night between the 4th
and the 5th of june 1968 the ambassador
hotel
los angeles robert f kennedy has just
announced his victory at the california
primaries to
an ecstatic crowd of supporters after a
brief speech bobby mingled with the
crowd and the hotel staff
according to witnesses he was moving
slowly through the hotel restaurant's
pantry when he reached out to shake the
hand of a busboy juan romero
a young man stepped out from the crowd
raised his arm and after shouting
kennedy you son of a [ __ ] he began
shooting
senator
okay now hold on to the guy hold on to
him we don't want another oswald
that man was sirhan sirhan a 24 year old
palestinian
refugee kennedy was hit three times in
his armpit
in the back and behind his right ear
members of his entourage apprehended
sarhan and
slammed him down on a metal table but he
was able to continue shooting wounding
five other bystanders as kennedy's
friends one of them a professional
football player struggled to pin down
the diminutive sergeant he yelled
let me explain let me explain i can
explain
i did it for my country i love my
country juan romero knelt to help bobby
who was on the floor bleeding
kennedy asked is everybody okay romero
replied that
yes everybody's okay bobby then turned
away and said
everything's going to be okay those were
his last words
robert kennedy died 26 hours later aged
his 11th child rory would be born six
months later
it's time now to examine the life of the
man on the other side of the gun
who was surhan sirhan and what had
driven him to murder robert kennedy
sirhan bashara sirhan was a jordanian
citizen born
on march 19 1944 in jerusalem mandatory
palestine into a
highly religious family of arab
christians he spent the early few years
of his life in his home country and also
completed his early schooling there
if you know even a little of middle
eastern history you may have guessed
that
being a palestinian child in the late
1940s did not make
for a quiet upbringing and surhan's
childhood was
no exception following the declaration
of israel as an independent state and
the subsequent declaration of war by the
surrounding arab countries
sergeant and his family would witness
violence on
a daily basis in one traumatic
experience surhan saw a man being
ripped to pieces during a bombing raids
in his neighborhood his mother mary said
that the image haunted her son
and he would never be the same again at
the age of 12 the sirhans had the chance
to emigrate to the united states as part
of a special visa program granted to
palestinian refugees
the young sergeant did not escape
completely from a life of violence
however as his father had a volatile
temper and would physically assault him
on several occasions
despite being an outsider with a
dysfunctional family sergeant adapted
quite well to american life he first
attended the elliott junior high school
in new york before the family relocated
to california where he enrolled in the
pasadena city college
sirhan was academically good and proved
his worth in both school and college
however despite having the chance to do
so he never applied for american
citizenship
and preferred to remain a jordanian
after graduating from pasadena sergeant
drifted from one job to another
never settling into a career and just
holding a series of menial jobs the only
career prospect that he considered
seriously
was horse racing at one point he found
himself working as a stable boy at the
santa anita racetrack
being only five feet five inches tall
and weighing 115 pounds
he had the perfect physique to become a
professional jockey but
his hopes they never materialized what
really defined him at this stage in his
life
was his religious belief he was an
ardent christian believer and he
experimented with different church
denominations shifting from
being a coptic to joining the baptist
and the adventist churches
in 1966 he finally joined the ancient
mystical order of the rose cross an
american branch of rosicrucianism
this is a mystical branch of
christianity which dates back to the
teachings of johann valetin andrea
a 27th century lutheran theologian
rosicrucians combined early christian
philosophy with alchemy
and even ancient egyptian mysticism and
they've been associated with freemasonry
and theosophism
through the ages we could talk about
this branch of religion for hours on end
but for the purpose of our story
we will only mention that sirhan's
association to this movement
has been linked to his shift towards
religious extremism
nationalism and possibly even
brainwashing
that there should be peace in the middle
east
so what we have so far is a deeply
religious yet alienated young man with
few prospects in life and a violent
upbringing but was this enough
to push him towards murder and why bobby
kennedy
importantly what was his relationship
with him cern would declare to
journalist david frost that he saw
robert kennedy as a hero
a protector of the downtrodden and the
disadvantaged he stated
i felt that i was one of those but this
perception
it changed in june of 1967 with the six
day war another victory which the state
of israel had against its arab neighbors
as a senator robert kennedy had openly
supported israel during that conflict
after announcing his candidacy in march
of 1968 as the new democratic hopeful
kennedy made his support of israel more
frequent and outspoken at a speech in a
synagogue broadcast via radio
kennedy pledged to support israel with
50 fighter jets
should he become president sergeant's
feelings towards the candidate they had
grown increasingly hostile since the
six-day war
after hearing the speech surhan had a
violent reaction that was witnessed by
his family
he screamed and he stormed out of the
room on the 18th of may surhan wrote in
his diary
my determination to eliminate rfk is
becoming the more and more
of an unshakable obsession kennedy must
die before june the 5th
die die die die die the 5th of june 1968
would have been the first anniversary
of the six-day war on the first of june
witnesses reported seeing sirhan at the
lock stock
barrel gun shop in los angeles where he
bought two boxes of 22-caliber
hollow-point bullets
on the 3rd of june he was spotted by
staff at the ambassador hotel apparently
surveying the site where
the presidential hopeful would be
expected to wait for the results of the
california
primaries on the following day on the
4th of june only hours before the
shooting
sergeant visited the san gabriel valley
gun club to
practice at the gun range and now we get
to the night of the 4th a few minutes
before midnight robert kennedy was
delivering the last lines of his speech
in the embassy ballroom at the
ambassador hotel while
sirhan was in the hotel's kitchen pantry
area waiting with a 22-caliber ivory
johnson cadet handgun in his pocket
ambassador employees jesus perez and
martin patrowski
remembered sirhan lingering around the
elevator area as kennedy was still on
the stage
and well you know what happened next the
screams the gunshots kennedy falling on
the floor while
sirhan was apprehended still yelling i
did it for my country
i wish that thinner candy was still
alive
i wish that every day that i've been
here sirhan initially refused to speak
or identify himself to the police it
wasn't until the 9th of june that he
decided to confess to the crime but on
insistence from his lawyers he retracted
his confession and pled not guilty the
trial took place between january
and april of 1969 and during the court
hearings sergeant behaved erratically
sometimes he claimed that on the night
of the murder he was drunk and that
he had no recollection of killing
kennedy while on other occasions he
stated that if he had killed him it
wasn't out of personal hatred but
as an act in service of his country
palestine
i'm not mentally ill but i'm not perfect
either these discrepancies
may have been a part of the defense
strategy based on the concept that
sirhan was
suffering from a condition known as
diminished capacity the jury
was not convinced though and eventually
surhan was found guilty of the murder
on the 17th of april 1969 and he was
sentenced to death
now this story might have ended here but
in 1972 the state of california declared
the death penalty to be unconstitutional
and so his sentence was commuted to life
in prison
sirhan sirhan has been a convict in the
california prison system
since then first serving time in san
quentin then soledad pleasant valley and
finally the richard donovan correctional
facility
in san diego over the years sirhan has
not been a silent convict
far from it in fact his lawyers have
been constantly filing requests for
parole hearings
one of these is held every five years
the last one in 2016
and they've all been rejected what is
interesting about these hearings though
is that they have given the chance to
surhan
his lawyers and his supporters to
present new evidence supporting the
claim
that he was not kennedy's assassin or at
least not a willing one or
maybe not the only one it's time now to
look at these theories and i hope you're
not easily offended by the c
word conspiracy
[Music]
the official explanation for the murder
of robert f kennedy is that sirhan
sirhan had acted alone because
he was mentally unstable because he
wanted to strike at an enemy
of the arab cause or maybe both this
would make bobby's murder the first
american encounter with
middle eastern terrorism over the years
many theories have emerged claiming that
surhan had not acted alone or that he
had simply been a pawn in the hands of a
more powerful and sinister force there
was a girl there
no no i don't remember much about that
what happened after that
you don't remember i don't remember at
the 2011 parole hearing sergeant's
attorney
larry teeter brought forward the
hypothesis that cern may have been
hypnotized brainwashed and
conditioned to carry out the
assassination of rfk he had been
identified and selected as a patsy or a
fall guy because
of his foreign origin and his support of
the palestinian cause
this theory is supported also by british
author peter evans in his book
nemesis according to evans and teeter
after interrogating sirhan the los
angeles police department could not
account for a period
of three months known as the white fog
during which sarhan's movements were
unknown it was during these days of
white folk that sergeant may have been
hypnotized by psychiatrist
dr william joseph bryan jr who had
worked on the infamous
cia mind control program called mkultra
this program was an expansion on two
pre-existing operations run by the cia
in the 1950s called project bluebird
and project artichoke both projects
envisioned the possibility
of using hypnosis as an interrogation
technique or as a way of manipulating a
foreign national and distress
foreign national here to carry out
political assassinations
bluebird artichoke and mk-ultra as
outlandish as they may sound
have all been acknowledged by the cia
and documentation related to them is
accessible via freedom of information
requests what is chilling is that the
official documentation for bluebird and
artichoke does not raise
any moral considerations around using
hypnosis
in interrogations or brainwashing
innocent people to
turn them into assassins the main
concern is sourcing
the right psychiatrist for the job
because a private practitioner would
likely not
accept a lowly cia salary apparently the
c
in cia stands for cheap but let's get
back to the 2011 parole hearing why did
the hypnosis theory
only emerge then well ironically it was
only then that attorney tita had the
idea to have cern hypnotized
to retrieve repressed memories of the
assassination
during those sessions surhan was able to
remember a detail that was previously
concealed he remembered meeting a girl
in a polka dot dress
on the night of the assassination he
said i was fascinated
with her looks she never said much it
was very erotic
i was consumed by her she was a
seductress with
an unspoken unavailability the girl took
him to the kitchen pantry and then
pinched him on the arm this was a
trigger action which led him to believe
that he was on a weapons firing range
and that's when sergeant began shooting
but who are the brains
behind this operation well according to
tita the assassination was staged by u.s
intelligence for the purpose of
continuing the war against vietnam and
putting the republican party in the
white house the assassination was
arranged with
the cia the fbi and the lapd
then there was a massive cover-up if he
had lived and been allowed to run
bobby kennedy would have been elected
president and this was a multi-agency
task force to make sure that the
democrats didn't take the white house
again
on the other hand peter evans states a
completely different theory
in nemesis sir had been hypnotized to be
at the ambassador and take the blame of
the actual assassin a
palestinian terrorist named mahmoud
hamsari and hamshari was himself
born on the payroll of none other than
greek magnate aristotle onassis
on asses was jackie kennedy's suitor at
that time so what was the motive here
well personal resentment towards bobby
who had foiled a major deal between
onassis and the saudis in 1953 and was
opposed to the greek billionaire
marrying his sister-in-law according to
evans the cia psychiatrist dr brian had
links to both hamshari and nasa's having
cured the former for migraine and
the latter for sexual dysfunction and
finally one of vanessa's lovers helen
gaye de nirgaard reported that he
himself had admitted his complicity in
the killing in 1974.
oh by the way dr brian he was found dead
in a las vegas hotel room in 1978 either
having shot himself
or having been murdered the case it
remains unsolved the brainwashing theory
is certainly fascinating and we know by
the cia's own admission
that the use of hypnosis to interrogate
or kill
was in their plans but something it
doesn't add up and just please note that
these
are our own personal considerations if
serhan had been programmed to believe he
was at a firing range shooting at
targets
if such a belief was triggered by the
pinch from the girl in the polka dot
dress
why did he shout kennedy you son of a
[ __ ]
why did he shout i did it for my country
if he was a patsy all along acting
mechanically at the tap of some girl in
polka dots
how could he behave in such a competent
way prior to the assassination
he knew what kennedy was due to speak he
visited the location he practiced at a
firing range and he acquired a
22-caliber gun
a low-powered pistol which is a perfect
choice for shooting in a closed
environment such as a pantry now this
choice of a weapon makes even more sense
if other assassins were there it would
make sense if there was another hitman
there who was more competent
who wanted to avoid the risk of being
hit by friendly fire
and while this brings us on to our
second conspiracy theory
[Music]
while researching the case for a
screenplay author and reporter shane
o'sullivan uncovered new video and
photographic evidence suggesting that
three senior cia operatives were behind
the killing this time
not as shady hypnotists but as hitmen
involved
directly in the assassination the first
agent is david sanchez morales known
for leading covert operations in latin
america as far back as 1973 morales had
been reported as saying
i was in dallas when we got the son of a
[ __ ] and i was in los angeles
when we got the little bastard of course
this refers to both kennedy brothers
analyzing footage and stills from the
night of the assassination
o'sullivan was able to identify morales
standing at the back of the ballroom in
the moments between the end of kennedy's
speech and the shooting
morales was also spotted alongside
another operative called gordon campbell
morales and campbell
had together worked at the cia's miami
base in 1963. both have been involved in
the planning of the bay of pigs invasion
and were harsh critics of the kennedys
blaming them for the failure of that
operation a third cia figure was
identified by looking at the crime scene
photos taken by the lapd
and this was george doanady's geranides
was chief of psychological warfare
operations at the miami base
whatever the involvement of morales
campbell and joanides
it is a shared belief that surham was
not the only shooter
at the ambassador hotel in the last
parole hearing in 2016 paul schrade one
of the
five other people injured in the
shooting said that the evidence clearly
showed
a second gunman had been in the kitchen
pantry first piece of evidence
the number of shots sir han's gun only
carried eight rounds and yet a radio
reporter recorded the sound of 13 shots
being fired in the pantry
this was confirmed by campaign volunteer
nina rhodes hughes who
reported to the fbi that she had heard
anywhere from 12 to 14 shots that night
bobby's own son robert kennedy jr
is convinced of this thesis as he
declared to the washington post
there were too many bullets you can't
fire 13 shots
out of an 8 shot gun the second point
direction of shooting how could sir had
shot kennedy
in the back and behind the ear if all
eyewitnesses confirmed that he was
standing
in front of him third distance los
angeles county coroner thomas naguchi
found that bobby's fatal head wound with
an entry trajectory from behind the ear
had been inflicted from a distance of
one inch to one and a half inches and
had been standing at least 18 inches
from him so another hitman
closer to bobby than sirhan was had shot
him behind the ear
at a close distance maybe it was morales
or campbell or
germany's or maybe it was someone else
according to some witnesses
a security guard called thane caesar
standing behind kennedy at the time was
seen drawing his weapon although we
should say that he was not seen
shooting and he later passed a polygraph
test that included questions about
whether he had shocked kennedy this
generation did not create most of the
conditions
the convictions which have led us to
this day but this generation
has a responsibility to resolve them we
have presented only
three possible theories about the
assassination of robert kennedy bobby
was a man
who could have shone a beacon of hope in
a traumatic period
of american history he could have ended
the vietnam war much earlier supported
the cause of the desperately poor and
accelerated the process of integration
brought about by the civil rights
movement
these progressive goals would be at
least partially achieved by
subsequent administrations but sadly at
that time they could have provided
enough motive for u.s intelligence
agencies or at least factions within
them
to be involved in bobby's killing and
what was sirhan's role in this event
was he really the victim of brainwashing
or maybe he was the willing participant
in a larger conspiracy
and just the only one to take any blame
we're going to stand by to hear from
sarahan's next parole hearing in 2021
hoping that maybe the truth will finally
emerge
whether we'll be able to handle it
though well that's another question
so i hoped you liked this new extended
format the way we sliced it up into kind
of three acts here please leave us your
comments below
if you did like it let us know if you
didn't also let us know but do hit that
thumbs up button and don't forget to
subscribe
also this video was super long and it
was all made possible thanks to
curiositystream
if you like the stuff we're making here
you will love them and it really does
support us so
please do click that link below and you
can get 30 days
for free and as always thank you for
watching